hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
complete history of the Forbidden Forest
a common backdrop for important moments
throughout the Harry Potter series for
both Harry his friends and his enemies
as many of you will remember the
Forbidden Forest is first introduced in
the Philosopher's Stone as a scary dark
place where students are not allowed to
enter never mind to roam about and
explore of course one very large caveat
to this rule is if those same students
ever find themselves in a bit of trouble
as much as it really makes absolutely no
sense whatsoever a punishment bestowed
upon multiple students over the years
including Harry Hermione Granger Neville
Longbottom and Draco Malfoy in the first
installment of the series is to send
them into the Forbidden Forest this form
of detention is meant to help Hagrid
with random duties required in the
upkeep of the portion of the forest that
resides on school proper
as this was the detention they were
given for merely being out of bed after
hours makes one wonder what the
punishment would have been for actually
going into the forest more time spent in
the forest like I said it really doesn't
make any sense at all anyway I'd like to
start off today's video with a brief
summary of The Forbidden Forest as we
know it through Harry Potter because
although there are many Fantastical
locations and magical places in which
Harry and his friends visit throughout
the novels and films alike it may not be
immediately apparent just how important
the Forbidden Forest is to the series
now is a very typical Trope for an
enchanted forest whether filled with
light magic or dark to represent a way
to achieve transformation for those who
enter it what I mean is that magical
forests are often used as a literary
device to be a catalyst of change for
any number of fictional characters they
entered the forest as one version of
themselves and emerge forever
transformed all this to say that I do
indeed believe believe there are quite a
few Transformations that take place
within the Forbidden Forest many of
which I will get into later in the video
but in my opinion it's quite evident
that the main transformation that takes
place in this series is at the very end
of the seventh book which as many of you
will know is the eighth movie and is
directly related to the protagonist of
the story our dear boy Harry the scene
that I'm referring to is the one in
which Harry enters the Forbidden Forest
as a human horcrux of Voldemort right
before the Battle of Hogwarts breaks out
Harry is ready to face immortality and
make the ultimate sacrifice die in an
effort to defeat the dark lord once and
for all and yet as we all know in dying
Harry fails quite miserably as on his
journey to the afterlife he ends up in
limbo having at long last a Frank and
honest discussion with former Headmaster
Albus Dumbledore only to then come back
from the dead without the fragment of
audible Soul inside of him
without the whole Crux inside of him
Harry is no longer connected to the dark
lord in summary Harry goes from
condemned wizard harboring a horcrux to
a very much alive confident young wizard
San horcrux delightful little bit of
transformation if I do say so myself no
more connection to the Baddie Lord
Voldemort the setting of The Forbidden
Forest for all of this also makes
complete sense given that it has been
said that this location is one of JK
Rowling's absolute favorites within
Hogwarts of course this little tidbit is
not completely relevant to the forest
history itself but it certainly supports
the idea as to why Rowling may have
chosen a magical forest like this to
represent Harry's final and most pivotal
transformation of the series alright so
knowing that the forest was likely
created by Rowling as a meaningful place
for Harry to finally overcome his
long-standing and ill-begotten
connection with Voldemort let's dive
into the many smaller Transformations
and events that took place within the
forest throughout the series book one
the Philosopher's Stone as briefly
mentioned at the start of the video in
the Philosopher's Stone Harry along with
Hermione Neville and Draco were all sent
into the Forbidden Forest as a form of
detention they were meant to accompany
Hagrid in an effort to locate a unicorn
known to have been badly injured
somewhere within the dark woods since
Hagrid isn't shall we say the best with
children he allows the group to split up
in order to cover more ground as they
search for the injured unicorn Harry and
Draco break off from the others only to
come upon a hooded figure feasting upon
the blood of the Unicorn they've been
looking for as we later find out this
hooded figure is actually a shadow
version of Voldemort upon being in such
close proximity to the dark lord Harry's
scar begins to sear with pain and he
passes out fortunately for Harry a
friendly Centaur by the name of frenze
finds him and desists him back to the
castle but not before explaining to him
that the dark hooded thing that Harry
saw feasting upon the Unicorn was
actually Voldemort attempting to return
to his full strength by way of drinking
the unicorn's blood in terms of
transformation what we see here is
Voldemort setting his path in motion to
go from the shadowy glimpse of his
former self that he's been stuck as for
more than a decade back towards his full
strength as the dark lord
Book 2 the Chamber of Secrets ah yes the
Chamber of Secrets presents us with a
whole new perspective on what fearsome
creatures lurk within the Forbidden
Forest for it's within this installment
of the series they'll be our first
introduce the forest's acromantula
colony a group of gigantic spiders led
by the acromanchula fondly known by
Hagrid as aragog this is when we see Ron
come face to face with one of his
greatest fears spiders and not just any
spiders enormous ones I would say that
Ron's ability to accompany Harry into
the colony's home shows great courage
and growth for Ron so although small I
would argue that this is our
transformation within the forest within
the Chamber of Secrets book 3 the
Prisoner of Azkaban there's also the few
times that certain care of magical
creatures lessons took place in the
Forbidden Forest which we see in great
detail in the Prisoner of Azkaban for
example this is where Hagrid teaches the
students about hippogriffs it's also
where we first meet Buckbeak of course
the Forbidden Forest plays a much larger
part in terms of Transformations later
on in the novel to start it's where
Lupine runs to after he has accidentally
transformed into a werewolf presumably
he changes back into a human within the
forest there's also a much more complex
transformation which occurs to Harry
within the forest near the end of the
Prisoner of Azkaban at the forest Black
Lake we see Dementors almost take the
souls of Harry Hermione and Sirius but
not before a future version of Harry
banishes the Dementors away with his
Patronus this means that the forest is
the very first place that Harry is able
to successfully cast his Patronus this
sets into motion a more confident
version of Harry allowing himself to
realize that he may be capable of more
than he thought book 4 The Goblet of
Fire Within the fourth novel in film The
Forbidden Forest is used as a way to
conceal the dragons that have to be
involved in one of the tasks of the try
was a tournament as part of the magical
inter-school tournament the Dragons Were
maintained by professional
dragonologists including Ron's older
brother Charlie Weasley during their
time in the forest this is not
particularly important except for the
fact that it's about dragons but later
in the Goblet of Fire the forest is the
location which a disheveled bartimus
Crouch senior stumbles into view with
his emergence from the forest we are to
later learn that who we thought was
Professor madai Moody was actually Barty
Crouch Jr in Disguise book 5 the Order
of the Phoenix in the Order of the
Phoenix much of the time Harry Ron and
Hermione spend in the forest is directly
linked to a well-intentioned hand grid
here during one of his care of magical
creatures classes we learn more about
the mysterious beings known as thestrals
the horse-like magical creatures who
pull the carriages of students from the
Hogwarts Express up to the castle these
beings are invisible to most and can
only be seen by people who have
witnessed death which becomes important
later on in the series as a
representation of the trauma that Harry
goes through after losing Sirius The
Forbidden Forest is also where we are
first introduced to Hagrid's
half-brother the giant named grop later
in the Order of the Phoenix Hermione
successfully manages to lure the nasty
defense against the dark arts Professor
Dolores Umbridge to the forest by
pretending that Dumbledore had hidden a
powerful weapon there although Hermione
likely had no real plan the group
fortunately comes across a herd of
centaurs and Umbridge unwisely insults
them she's then carried off but Harry
and Hermione are able to escape thanks
for grop's timely intrusion on the chaos
book 6 the Half-Blood Prince this is the
only installment in the series in which
Harry and friends orphos do not find
themselves in the Forbidden Forest book
7 the Deathly Hallows and of course who
could forget that the Forbidden Forest
is the location where Harry at long last
comes up against Voldemort meeting his
death and returning from his version of
limbo all in just a few short scenes
this series of events begins with
Voldemort issuing the following
ultimatum to Harry from his temporary
headquarters in the forest I shall wait
for one hour in the Forbidden Forest if
at the end of that hour you have not
come to me have not given yourself up
then battle recommences finally
understanding what he must do Harry
enters the Forbidden Forest and uses the
resurrection Stone to visit one last
time with the loved ones he has lost
including his mum dad Godfather Sirius
and Remus Lupine it seems only fitting
that his reunion of this sword happens
in the dark and mysterious confines of
the forest after gaining strength from
their otherworldly visit Harry drops the
stone leaving it among the darkness as
one of the many Secrets now kept in the
Forbidden Forest it's mentioned later on
that a centaur joining the Battle of
Hogwarts steps on it press it into the
forest ground forever burying it in an
unmarked area of the woods honorable
mentions of the Forbidden Forest
although not nearly as prominent as the
scenes just discussed there are a few
other points that revolve around the
forest throughout the Harry Potter
series that deserve a mention for
starters there's much talk throughout
the series regarding Fred and George
Weasley's preoccupation with the
Forbidden Forest although it's never
revealed why the twins may have been so
interested in the wooded area
fired the gas though I'd wager that
they'd seen something of interest on the
Marauders map it would be interesting to
know what exactly they were so Keen to
look for in the forest though perhaps
something to discuss in another video
and let's not forget that Hagrid's Hut
was also located right on the edge of
the forest of course Harry visited
Hagrid frequently throughout the series
and always received much value from his
visits emotional and otherwise but of
course all of this is just a mere
glimpse into the entire history of the
Forbidden Forest for our dear Harry only
attended Hogwarts for a brief six years
as he was trotting the globe in search
of Voldemort's horcruxes during what
would have been his seventh year at the
magical school and so through the
chronicles of Harry Potter we are only
given a very slight overview of what has
gone on in this Forest over the
centuries for example when did it become
known as The Forbidden Forest why was
the School for Children built right
alongside it with all this in mind
there's likely an incredibly Rich
backstory for this mysterious location
so let's dig into the earlier history of
this daunting wood the early history of
the Forbidden Forest The Forbidden
Forest as it is primarily known amongst
the students of Hogwarts is also
referred to by The Wider Wizarding World
as the Dark Forest as we've already
discussed at much length a portion of
the forest is located within the grounds
of Hogwarts along the edges of the
property it is incredibly old with first
known Mention Of It Dating back to as
early as the first Millennium in fact
it's believed that the forest was
originally a small simple wood inhabited
in CAD 4 by only a herd of Lone centaurs
as it was no one quite knows exactly
when it garnered its current reputation
for harboring some of the most Dark and
Dangerous magical creatures or when it
grew to such a size as it stands today
it's important to note however that the
Forbidden Forest is also home to a few
more friendly magical beings as well
being that the forest is so ancient
filled with gnarled Beach Oak Pine
Sycamore and yew trees that have lived
for centuries alongside mysterious and
Sinister looking black flowers the
forest is also said to hold many Secrets
unbeknownst to the larger magical
Community due to the lack of visitors
from outside the forest there are very
few paths except for near the entrances
even here those who dare Venture inside
are met with thorns and large Roots
known to make it incredibly difficult to
pass through the brush and yet we know
from characters like bartima's Crouch
senior who stumbled out of the Forbidden
Forest near the end of the Goblet of
Fire that it was possible to Traverse
the forest and access the grounds of
Hogwarts from the outside world simply
by navigating your way through it that
said I suppose with all the dark and
Sinister creatures who live within the
forest it's likely not quite as easy as
simply walking on through despite the
level of difficulty required to make
one's way through the Dark Forest it
does seem like a giant oversight by
those who founded Hogwarts do have not
built some form of barrier between the
school grounds and the outside world as
it stands it seems like an incredible
flaw in the protection of the school
students but I digress due to its
proximity to the school grounds as well
as what we know about the location of
Hagrid's Hut it likely comes as no
surprise that the boundary of the
Forbidden Forest was the home of many
Hogwarts groundskeepers including and
prior to rubius Hagrid the presumption
here is that each groundskeeper was
charged with keeping tabs on the forest
and tending to any known altercations or
other important matters that may have
Arisen within it the first documented
event within the Forbidden Forest that
we know of occurred in the late 1970s
when someone presumably a student of
Hogwarts Disturbed what was known as the
forest Vault this Vault was one of five
legendary cursed vaults within the
school all and upon its disturbance it
Unleashed a terrible sleepwalking curse
upon the pupils of Hogwarts which led to
many students venturing into the
Forbidden Forest as they slapped
tragically this sleepwalking epidemic
resulted in multiple deaths and many
injuries at this time a Hogwarts student
named Jacob attempted to break the curse
with the help of a centaur who went by
the name of torvis unfortunately torvis
refused to hand over what Jacob required
to break the curse as what the young
wizard needed was a precious heirloom to
the Centaur a jewel-adorned arrowhead
this led to Young Jacob stealing the
heirloom never to return it to the
Centaur or Forest as he was expelled
before he was able to do so there's also
knowledge of a former Hogwarts Professor
who taught care of magical creatures
Sylvanas kettleburn spending a
significant amount of time within the
forest and tragically he was the one
responsible for sharing insights into
how one could enter the Forbidden Forest
undetected by broom with a particularly
troubled young wedge Patricia rake pick
is said that this information led to
Patricia having unauthorized access to
the forest which ultimately contributed
to her ability to murder a fellow
student Rowan Khanna within the wooded
setting sadly this is just one of the
many tragic ends that Arthur unnamed
Hogwarts students met within the
Forbidden Forest as it is common
knowledge that more than a few pupils
disappeared into the forest over the
years never to be seen again and with
that we've come to the end of another
video what do you think did I miss
anything about the Forbidden Forest
history what are your thoughts on the
importance of this mysterious location
and its proximity to Hogwarts please
share your thoughts in the comments
below and as always if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget and to live